- hello Super Trouper army
I am your general foolish Maximus and I
welcome you all here today my beautiful
wife is not here she's at home with the
family I am however excited to announce
that I have finally part tooken and
mommy makeout day as I am now a father
and my wife is a mom that I have kissed
my wife and therefore I have
participated in mommy makeout day so
that's a really bold and exciting
announcement regulars thank you thank
you very much damn appreciate that
today's episode is sponsored by raking
stitch fix ring and honey and anyone
that is interested in streaming the
audio side of this podcast I would love
if you guys would stream it on Spotify I
think that's a preferred place to do it
our podcast is there thank you
before we get started today I want to
talk about the theodore and a lot of
other stuff these beauty gurus you know
I said it previously when we were
talking about Tati
and Tati was all butthurt that James
Charles didn't promote her supplements
or her vitamins I'm like who the [ __ ] is
this person to be making supplements to
begin with okay and now it's come out
that the FDA is recalling some of these
beauty products products for having get
this asbestos why is there even asbestos
in so that's just a topical thing I
imagine what's that what could actually
be in the [ __ ] that you're eating that
hasn't been you know it hasn't been
looked at by the FDA so I had a feeling
there was some weird [ __ ] going on here
we're gonna jump into that later before
we do get into any of that there's a
video that is of paramount importance
this was a rescue these firefighters
rescued a 74 year old woman who was
injured while hiking and boy what a
rescue it was let me tell you they they
she found herself wishing that she was
crawling to the back to the road like
before the helicopter arrived
oh I should enjoy this okay we're having
some play button malfunctions here
anytime didn't you imagine your ass
getting picked up
you like finally help is here and all
the sudden your ass is spinning like 200
rpm so this dude just has his foot in it
as far as I could tell dude homie has
his foot on the street he gave out he's
trying to stop the spinning but yeah but
he just gave up he's like alright this
[ __ ] is gonna spin oh my god and for
some reason you know for some reason
that oh my god that's a lot of rpm
anyway before you before you think this
is important
I would like to comfort everybody but
it's so great and the fact that it was
captured
oh they're just gonna take off they just
flew at the end there I saw the
interview they had to because the whole
reason was happening is though the wind
was getting kicked up in Canyon there so
like they thought the best option was to
just get the hell out of that area so
it'll stop but yeah it's what I love
they just peaced out they probably just
flew all the way home with her dangling
from the back like a Jackie Chan movie
yeah I gotta watch that again they're
like you know what she's probably toast
so let's get the [ __ ] out of here
ah and for those reasons amount I love
it man peace and the best part is like
she's all zipped up I don't even think
she can see all she did was like sprain
her ankle and now she's on the back of a
death
ride oh so good she's fine okay so don't
feel too bad he did survive no injury no
additional injuries I mean physical
injuries I don't know about trauma
mental trauma oh man she's never going
hiking again I'm never going hiking
again that's fine I never went hi can
you begin with so let me give you a
little update we actually we've been
having a really tough time actually now
Theodore's doing fantastically but when
we first came home I guess ela wasn't
like lactating enough and he wasn't
eating enough and he was like starving
we didn't really know like the first
night back I'm trying to think how it
wind up with the last episode we did I
think it was after that yeah was the
night after that podcast or the night of
that podcast
he was just inconsolable
like I mean newborns are supposed to
sleep like 18 hours a day he probably
slept for five hours and he was like ten
out of ten hysteria crying the rest of
the time and we just we couldn't figure
it out we didn't understand what we were
doing wrong we don't know II was so
upset so he took him to the doctor the
next day on Sunday that was like the
longest day of my life bro like
seriously one of the worst days of my
life just pacing back and forth with him
for hours and just unconsolable and he
wasn't peeing at all which is really
concerning because it means he's like
super dehydrated
and I was calling like a helpline all
night which was so unfuckin helpful they
just keep asking me like so many
questions I mean it was a Kaiser
helpline so I figured they would [ __ ]
know what the hell what they were doing
but they just kept asking me questions
in like and at the end I was like listen
is there are we going anywhere with this
because like I need to actually attend
to my child and I just ended up hanging
up with hanging up with him but we ended
up seeing the doctor the next day and
Theodore had lost like ten percent of
his body weight which babies are
supposed to lose a lot of weight after
they're born because there's kind of
like a couple days grace period before
they start feeding because like it takes
time for a mother's milk to come in but
he wasn't really getting any food
he was breastfeeding so it's hard to
know how much is coming out but he
wasn't getting any food and he lost like
ten percent of his body weight and he
was just he was just hysterical and it
was it was hard it was really
devastating it was a really really hard
night but I'm glad we went to the doctor
the next day which they started feeding
him formula and the moment we gave him
that first bottle of formula it was like
the first time he ever ate his he was
crying inconsolable you put the thing in
his mouth and his eyes just glaze over
he's like crying and then glazed over
sucking like the best thing ever he's
just he goes from like a ten he's just
going hysterical - it was a mate it was
so such a relief so amazing to see him
so happy and he he literally chugged
that [ __ ] down and immediately was just
like fell asleep and since we figured it
out he's just been sleeping like a he's
like a perfect angel I mean he eats he
shits he sleeps I don't think he's even
cried one single time since that's nice
that's awesome I mean he really is just
such an angel
mm-hmm yeah he's doing great but he so
we were kept feeding him and then the
next day we went back for another
follow-up appointment and he still
hadn't peed though which I guess is just
because he was so dehydrated and lost so
much weight that his body just was using
all the liquid was pretty crazy
now he's peeing like non-stop I mean the
dude is a pee machine a poop machine
he's crushing it but he had him peed in
like 48 hours and so we went to the
doctor and the doctors was super
concerned that he had impede and we kept
feeding him and feeding him while we
were there and the doctor said you got
to wait here until he pees we need to
know what's going on so so we're there
for three hours feeding him and he
doesn't freaking pee and the doctor says
that he she needs to put a catheter in
him whoa and we were and that was like
ela was hysterical she was crying she
was super upset and it's you know I mean
that's gotta be [ __ ] up like there's
no painkillers involved he's this little
guy he's just you know how the hell did
you put a catheter and a newborn baby he
just [ __ ] up so I said listen let's
just wait one more hour okay let's keep
feeding him let's just wait one more
hour I know he's eating and luckily we
never had to put the catheter in him
thank God but the nurse would came out
they were ready to take him away and put
a catheter and it turns out that
actually on diapers there's like a
yellow line that turns blue when they
pee it gets wet and for some reason the
line hadn't turned to blue but we think
he had made a pee in his diaper and so
show the doctor and she says okay send
him home we'll send you guys home we're
not gonna do the catheter just keep an
eye on him
we took him home and lo and behold the
guy hasn't stopped peeing since so we
averted that crisis thank God that would
have just been so true
and I had if the thing was that he was
sleeping peacefully he was so happy and
content because he was eating he was
sleeping so he wasn't in any discomfort
so I was like there's no freaking way
that we need to put a catheter in this
dude if he was in pain if he was crying
if he was suffering then I would be like
yeah you know let's figure out what's
going on but the fact that he was so
content made me very apprehensive and
luckily it's all good
so it's been a it's been um it was a
really probably little ball I swear to
God was one of the long stays like I
called my mom at 4:30 and I was like mom
you have to come right now because I
hadn't slept and probably like 48 hours
and me Neela were just he was just
crying just crying crying crying crying
crying and there was just nothing we
could do to console him and I was just
like and nobody really understood what
was going on a lot of people were being
like oh that's just normal you know he's
a newborn baby it's just I don't know it
just didn't seem normal that he was so
inconsolable but we finally figured it
out and my mom came over at 4:30 and
watched him and we got to sleep for
three hours but I was just we were both
really that was one of the longest days
ever
that being said he's sleeping like a
champ it's so it's so nice now like we
went through baby boot camp because now
it's like what the formula - because
he'll is still pumping breast milk so
he's getting both kind of which is good
but were able to take shift-select
he needs to eat every three hours so at
one o'clock Eva will feed him let's just
say and then in three hours I wake up
and I feed him the the formula because
ela doesn't need to be awake to
breastfeed him you feed him you burp him
you know you check you change his diaper
and then he's sleeping like a goddamn
angel a blessed angel I'm not gonna say
goddamn about my own child
he's a blessed angel
so we actually are able to get like six
hours stretch of sleep when we're on
shift so it's actually great and then
during the day he just sleeps and we
hang out and it's so cute he sleeps on
you it's like the sweetest thing when
you feed him and then when he's done he
just will pass out right on your chest
like this it's the cute is the best so
it's it's fun man it's been great it's
been fantastic
everyone's doing good yields recovering
well
ela already looks like she was never
pregnant it's like magic I don't know
what's going on with her she's like
wearing her normal clothes and [ __ ] I
was like whoa where did you come from
come here mommy make out there you got a
piece of that ass girl anyway let's
segue into something more important like
how I've been feeling lately Lance door
Lant dude genius is really trolling us
at this point they have to be there like
okay Lance Stewart made up song that
everybody hated let's get him on genius
here just come here let me give you a
taste of this bro we don't need an
analysis of I'm lost you know what I
mean this is deep [ __ ] not easy
also his cross is super-weird get a load
of his cross it looks like it's dripping
blood or some [ __ ] or boogers like why
so gruesome Doug isn't it dripping blood
or something seems yeah it's melting
maybe something going on I don't get the
imagery either way it's a little hard
dude dude he's wounded right now go easy
his long tongue young Lance here I don't
remember who who had this bit maybe it
was like Eddie Izzard he had such a
great bit about he's like if Jesus came
back do you really think he would want
to see a crucifix everywhere like that's
how he died that's how he was tortured
to death like him all the things do you
really think he would want to see a
crucifix everywhere that's like John
Lennon coming back and like man whatever
I'm not I hate retelling jokes what do I
do this to myself God go watch Eddie
Izzard
yeah after this podcast thank you for
watching but anyway here's the real deal
so where is it like how I've been
feeling lately
get your notebooks out too many visions
from this place of you and me everywhere
don't explain the lyrics you know I'm
walking down the street well so this
lyric means I was a huh I was on the
street using my legs to walk and there
was a street and I was walking and I was
going from one place to another so is
that good it's like what the hell we
doing I it's me of my ex-girlfriend I
mean for example we used to live in the
same house together I still currently
live in that house that so every single
day I just get like flashbacks on my
head of like you know I'll be in the
kitchen and it reminds me I've been
cooking in the kitchen it definitely
makes it harder to be in my house I've
felt very like negative energy over the
past couple months just being there
because you know these memories I'm
trying to get these memories out of my
head but it's super hard just being in
the same spot where all those memories
began see yo silhouette inside my
king-sized heavy lies the crown without
the Queen bro okay let me you know
analyze your lyrics your king-size bed
what a pimp
by the way heavy lies the crown without
the queen man poetic it's like
Shakespeare bro what do you think you're
a king with a crown you think you're the
king heavy lies is more so relating
towards you know being in my bed and
seeing her silhouette and like I just
feel like wait no no have you lies the
crown dumbass do you not even know what
it heavy lies
oh he doesn't even understand the
expression
heavy lies and then does he think it's
heavy lies the crown brown is great with
did he write these lyrics lies is more
so relating towards you know being in my
bed and snow it's about the crown I just
feel like a weight of pressure on me
every time I'm in my bed and I'm not
seeing her there and the lyric the crown
without the Queen is just me feeling
like you know I once had my queen and
now I don't have a queen anymore so it's
it's just a weird feeling being in bed
all the time and not having a
significant other
don't explain this don't you [ __ ]
dare explain this don't you dare break
this down because some days there was
just there was a reward but somedays I
just you know just completely go back
down and feeling like crap depressed
every day not really know what you're
doing not really know where you're going
in life just not understanding how to
get out of that feeling so much on my
mind yeah losses said boy he's doing his
own backup vocals
well he's I mean you don't have to do
the backup vocals did oh man this is too
good
get out of that feeling so much on my
mind yeah mmm lost the side of my head
how'd it go so left when me and use the
right fit I honestly felt like we were
good for each other but we weren't at
the same time for example I know every
couple argues we you know we argued a
little bit too much as much as we wanted
to make it work
we just knew it couldn't had you in my
palms now you're gone I lost my grip
whoa whoa back it up wait I gotta hear
the head you you hear me I had you you
had me whoa no water dream whoa what's
that sorry Lance I know you got this you
got this bleeding cross and everything
am i trying to [ __ ] your [ __ ] up but let
me hear that one more time
I had you you had me the loves gone it
can't leave me you can't play me broken
heart come fix my pieces hasn't been the
same no no what is felt different for me
since the Bradley Lance oh [ __ ] Lance
claimed all of our [ __ ] studio71
yeah city 71 is one of these empty ends
that is absolute probably one of the
full of the worst people the worst
people I mean they used to be yeah this
was the one we creative what was it what
was there well how were they previously
known as I'll look it up creative
something but their mandate and they've
been sitting on it like I think they're
intentionally just sitting on it so that
they can what they do they're doing
spitefully is they'll claim it I dispute
it but in that time they can turn off
all the ads and then in 30 days they'll
probably just collective Digital Studios
they changed their name to studio 71
because they had gotten so much bad
publicity for being a predatory shitty
MCN they rebranded themselves as studio
71 and they claimed our entire podcast
and they turned off all the ads why
would they do that unless they planned
on dropping the claim and just oh right
letting it come back and but but I don't
earn any money at all right if they turn
there's no reason to turn off the ads
other than because if they thought they
were gonna win the claim they would keep
the ads on and make the money right so
they've done that's coming ya know
they're the worst and I know there's
people there that hate me because of we
used to be with them and they totally
[ __ ] us over they totally [ __ ] us
over they are the worst MCN by far and I
totally don't put it past them to do
something that's sleazy so yeah I mean
what why why else turn off the ads other
than yeah to [ __ ] with you if you really
if you care then then block it worldwide
you know or do or two
mca right so and like we had a bunch of
other claims on that episode and they've
all been dropped since then there were
all these people who were kind enough to
release the claim when i disputed it but
these guys have been sitting on it now
for like two weeks turned all the ads
off and are not responding
so what will happen is after 30 days of
them not responding it will get released
and then and then i'll get the ads back
turned on usually they'll keep that ads
on and monetize it and then it will go
into a escrow account and I'll get that
when I win the dispute but they have the
ability to turn off the ads when they
claim it and so they basically just
[ __ ] me because like if we can't earn
money then I think they're just doing it
spitefully honestly it's hard to not
interpret it that way because again I
mean what motivation could they possibly
have to not well there's there's
somebody in that company that that got
it out for you I think so I really do
because we embarrassed them several
years ago when all this [ __ ] went down
with them they I'll tell you dude these
guys are the worst man they made ELA cry
like seriously it was that bad this was
when we had first moved back from Israel
yeah you mentioned this on the PATA a
couple weeks I had yeah there's a dude
named Brian there who specifically was
our the guy who got us to sign up and he
goes where there was this really
important thing called man uh it doesn't
really exist anymore but it was called a
managed Channel and what it did is it
let you bypass the copyright system so
that you want to get automatically
claimed they got rid of that so nobody
has that access anymore but they said
absolutely you'll have that no problem
no not at issue this was long time ago
this was a standard [ __ ] a lot of people
had this and when we joined up they
didn't put us in managed and they
refused to put us in managed and we're
like ok well clearly this is a
misunderstanding so just you know
release us from the contract and we'll
go our separate ways and they frickin
refused they flat out said they said no
you signed the contract
yours have to stay with our MCN no and
this was before like now YouTube has
done more to prevent this kind of pretty
taury behavior like you can disconnect
yourself now but before you could not
disconnect only they could disconnect
you and they would and then it was like
why are you doing this she actually
starts crying she's so upset like why
are you doing this to us there's there's
no reason for this Oh Mike did my
computer turn off I think my computer
turned off ooh does that matter for the
audio or no just keep going I'll work on
it
I was weird where's the power button on
this thing I think I got it and so oh
there you go just slept and went to
sleep maybe I accidentally push the
sleep button so I said ela scratch the
why are you doing this just we clearly
don't want to be in this relationship
just just you know release us and we'll
set go our separate ways and they said
to her like it's time for you I swear to
god this guy said this to her it's time
for you to grow up you signed a contract
and now you have to live with it it's
time for you to start acting like an
adult and I was like [ __ ] you did not
[ __ ] go there with us and I and I
went and I put these [ __ ] this was
during the time when like prank invasion
did a DMCA on us and we did this whole
video about fullscreen and and and we
felt like our MC was supposed to be on
our side and they were telling us to
erase the video and erase our tweets and
[ __ ] and I was like what who the [ __ ] is
either so I go to Twitter I'm like hey
by the way collective Digital Studios is
is [ __ ] conning us and and you know
keeping us in a contract we don't want
to be in it just whatever talking about
it and then these stupid [ __ ] these
[ __ ] they rot once I start
bitching about them on Twitter guess
what they do immediately release us and
they get to try to get us to sign some
document saying that we won't disparage
them I was like [ __ ] you not signing
[ __ ] [ __ ] you suck my dick
and drop and and let me out and they did
and I found out later that that guy
Brian who was working with other people
I knew was tattling people has other
members of the MC n-not to work with me
because
was toxic and trouble he was telling
them not to work with me
it's wild trying black clothes dear who
by the way get a grip you don't have it
this isn't Hollywood [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
MCN phone thinking blacklist is yourself
you had to change your own name remember
idiots studio 71 you can't [ __ ] run
away from the fact that your ass yeah I
remember who you are studio 71
[ __ ] so here they are up to the
same [ __ ] and it may well be the same
[ __ ] guy who's behind it so Brian if
you're listening suck my dick
I still remember [ __ ] you and [ __ ] your
MCN and you're becoming irrelevant
nobody even needs him scenes anymore so
suck my huge huge swollen nuts all right
[ __ ] you dude
so I think that's what it is there
despitefully trying to [ __ ] me over
so fine dude that's how you want to play
it I'll get it back in about two weeks
and even though you stole thousands of
dollars from me you had a chant you had
to rebrand your company because you were
so ass and I'm sure that cost more than
that so eat [ __ ] [ __ ] you and I don't
need to talk ship on your back I'll tell
everyone right now don't work with
studio71 who you can not get slam on
them with the regular mega lot I can't
get over Lance's necklace why is it
using yeah oh you can't see on the
screen here why we who's in here folks I
think it's supposed to be like the blood
that's so graphic yeah I mean come on
guys this this is not and what are we
doing here why is Christianity come to
this point where we need like a
blood-stained cross is that really
appropriate like why do we remember
Jesus for for the moment where he was
tortured and bled to death on the cross
are we not meant to appreciate his
moment like the goodness that we're
supposed to celebrate the good things he
done not a blood-stained cross I mean
how is this the the image that we've
come to embrace it just seems ridiculous
well the the blood is a it's a bit extra
as I've never seen that or yeah I've
never seen but even the cross cut the
cross we think of Jesus but what the
cross really is
people were frequently crucified in Rome
that was a way of putting people to
death it was a horrible torturous thing
to do yeah be weird if it water it's
like putting a guillotine on a necklace
yeah you know it's like putting a
[ __ ] a noose
you know I hang a hangman's it's just
come on guys find a better image why the
[ __ ] we walk around crosses yeah I mean
I'm not gonna claim to be an expert on
Christianity at all but um you know him
him dying on the cross it was it was a
sacrifice for for humanity and so you
know there I think the explanation would
be that you're honoring that sacrifice
but like you said I mean let's honor the
man's life though right yeah it's like
why the why the method of death
specifically but name the symbol is
gruesome later I'm not gonna walk around
with a guillotine on my [ __ ] the same
thing really what if it a diamond then
yes I would wear it oh yeah blood of
ruby encrusted blood trips anyway Lance
is [ __ ] god bless Oh Lance if you
hear this please talk to your studio and
at least the claim and if Bryan's is
your wrapped home I said [ __ ] him tell
him I said it [ __ ] that idiot such a
douche when I found out he was talking
[ __ ] behind my back to other people
telling him not to work with me I was
like ooh I see how it is what a douche
you don't make it look crying get away
with that [ __ ] y'all changed your
[ __ ] name and I remember who you are
you can never hide from this oh yeah
when it disconnected I think I got all
garbled you know what it's time for
break in a moment anyways oh isn't so
why don't we do that and we'll fix
alrighty guys stay tuned we're gonna get
into these beauty gurus selling poisons
so you will not want to miss that I
guarantee see you soon
the year is 2019 we all need a great
pair of Bluetooth earbuds and before you
go spend hundreds of dollars on one of
these huge overpriced name brands I need
you to check out Raik on these things
are the real deal okay first let me show
you what's in the box
you got the carrying case that you
charge it directly in you pop open this
magnetized top and what's inside these
slick beautiful little babies that fit
beautifully select discreet stylish even
in your ear and deliver what may be the
best audio experience on the planet
today beautiful there's no tangles
there's no strings there's a freaking BS
some of these some of these ear buds out
there you're practically tripping over
these are slick and beautiful and it
also comes with this little slick credit
card full of ear sizes so if you've got
a big ass chubby ear hole or a tiny
little petite ear hole they got you
covered that I like - its half the
frickin price of all the other premium
wireless earbuds on the market and they
sound just as amazing the company was
actually co-founded by Ray J and other
celebrities like Snoop Dogg okay these
guys know what they're doing when it
comes to audio these recon have changed
the game for me super comfortable and
they're easy to take absolutely anywhere
ray con offers their wireless earbuds
for everyone in a range of fun colors
and an unbeatable price so if you are
looking for some beautiful stylish
discreet well sounding earbuds head on
over to buy a condo complex rating you
get 20% off your order
damn that's a buy rake on Comm slush HD
for 20% off
rake on wireless earbuds if you've been
eyeing a pair now is the time to get an
amazing deal one more time go to buy
rake on Comm slash HD for 20% off
not all clothes fit for all men with
stitch fix your personal stylist will
send you clothing that makes you look
and feel your best it's not a one size
fits all it's a this fits your style
this is what stitch fix does this is why
I love them situating is an online
personal stylist service that delivers
your favorite clothing brands right to
your door to get started you go to
stitch fix comm slash h3 answer some
questions about your preferred style and
your preferred your personal shopper
will ship you a box of clothes shoes
accessories within your budget and
exactly to your specifications and
there's no commitment required you only
pay for what you keep shipping exchanges
returns are always free plus the $20
styling fee is automatically applied
towards anything you keep from your box
so essentially if you buy anything it
ends up being free but here's also the
great thing you can always return you
know it's basically you're turning your
home into your personal changing room
send you stuff you try it on if you like
it you keep it if you don't you send it
back it's a beautiful thing it's so
convenient
you never have to think about looking
good again with stitch fixed so to get
started guys head on over to stitch fix
comm slash h3 and you're gonna get an
extra 25% off when you keep everything
in your box
that's stitch fix comm slash h3 stitch
fix comm slash h3
I love ring it is a product that has
changed my life it's one of these
products that is just so revolutionary
it's so incredible I cannot recommend it
enough their mission is to make
neighborhoods safer but what they've
done for me they've made my house so
safe and so secure I feel so comfortable
there they've got a doorbells
they've got spotlights but they all
basically have the same function in that
it's got a camera it's got a motion
detector when somebody walks in front of
it and a motion sensor goes off it gives
you a notification on your phone and you
can pull up the live feed but that's not
all it actually beams up to the cloud
the recording of the incident so even if
you don't get it right away or even if
something happens maybe you've got a
criminal mastermind coming and turning
your power off well too late [ __ ]
because it already got beamed up to the
cloud and I can view it anytime from
anywhere okay it's not a speaker I could
talk to them they could talk to me they
it's got that the the spotlights got a
siren on it you could blast them with
that I mean that it's incredible I have
a ring around my house literally and
nothing gets by me I feel so safe and so
secure there beyond even the traditional
alarm system I mean this changes
everything on top of that they've got
the neighborhood app so you can talk to
people in your neighborhood nearby that
also have ring which is a lot and you
can talk you share videos you know
exactly what's going on your
neighborhood this product is incredible
it's a game-changer
I cannot recommend it enough as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and
motion-activated flood bike cam the
starter kit has everything you need to
build a ring of security around your
home so go to ring.com slash h3 that's
ring.com slash h3 get started try this
product out it's gonna change your life
I swear on it thank you
here's something we can all agree on
here's something we can all agree on
money we like saving money it's the best
feeling in the world and that's what
honey is all about okay if you're not
shopping around you're probably not
saving the most money but what if there
was a way for somebody to do the
shopping around for you well that's
exactly what honey does and he's a free
tool that you download on your
computer's browser while you shop online
honey scans the internet for coupon
codes and other discounts then it
automatically applies the coupons with
the biggest savings to your cart at
checkout like magic and it is magic it
works on over 20,000 sites like Amazon
Nordstrom's j.crew Nike Best Buy Target
Macy's and more it takes zero effort to
install it's just two clicks and you're
ready to start saving anytime you shop
instead of taking my word for it here's
what actual downloaders and fans of our
says here the very first day I use this
I save 10 bucks on Amazon and then
another 30 bucks on a subscription
service I couldn't stop using the
service if I tried you don't have to try
thanks a shree shree and thank you honey
another dude said you just saved me 81
dollars amazing shout out to h3 show you
what up pimps what up pimp to you I use
honey I can't stop using it either
because it's effortless it's easy it is
like magic it just automatically applies
the coupons I checkout boom boom boom
it's literally it's free to download I
mean give it a shot here folks
there's really not any reason not to use
honey it's free to use easy to install
on your computer and just two clicks and
if and if you don't think it for me take
it from our fans who also how are saving
a Frick load of money so get honey for
free at join honeycomb slash a tree
that's join honey calm slash h3 it's
honey
the smart shopping assistant that saves
you time and money
welcome back everybody I'm I was lost
but now I'm found
or my found found I'm lost I'm lost I'm
found
yeah I'm found I don't understand why
he's found yeah he didn't really expand
on the found part in in his lyrics it
seems mostly lost but right right Zach
do you have any insight cause you're a
you're a musician there's no structure
to that song it's just all over the
place yeah but why is he found I think
he found that cross maybe it's a like a
religious thing oh he's bound he's born
exactly Wow have you ever had such a
rough breakup the fountain Jesus can't
say I haven't been there well Lance has
a bloody cross he went all out
mm-hmm do you guys know who Jojo see
what am I saying that right
yeah and vaguely Jojo over this girl
that's just great right there that's a
wonderful this is her car now what's the
background this is one of the girls who
got caught selling asbestos right this
is asbestos paid for this car what's
that you guys know she was on some
reality show Dancing with mom or like a
beauty mom no Dance Moms is what it was
called I believe which chronicles the
child abuse of mothers essentially yes
yes let's pull up a clip yeah this was
like a regular on on the soup back in
the day of just shitty really cringey
clips
oh my god why am I watching this world
oh it's Jojo
jazz routine Petrin is learning her
routine as well I don't want them
sitting so this is crazy ass mom yeah I
think running boot camp on their low
kids right so this show was popular yes
well anyway she was one of the stars
from this and she's huge on YouTube now
and she's selling a bunch of products my
goodness she's built like an entire
empire unfortunately one of those items
was recalled by the FDA the FDA made a
tweet recently and issued a warning here
at first let's start with this tweet
this is amazing today the FDA is
releasing new results from its continued
testing of cosmetic products for
asbestos and is warning consumers do not
use two additional products that have
been tested positive for asbestos and
have been recalled look at this [ __ ]
that's a little death box little death
box of joy why the hell is there
asbestos in this [ __ ] to begin with I
mean do you want your child's face to
light on fire is that what you're saying
right now I mean how could that be a
useful product it's fire resistance dude
oh is that what it is I don't know what
I don't know what the actual reason for
it being in there that's I mean that's
the main purpose of asbestos right
fireproofing I honestly I think it's
insulation in homes and stuff I tell you
I'll give you my little anecdote about
asbestos there was some in our house
because it was old from the 50s and the
guys had to come clean it up with a city
approval and you have to wet it down
before you clear it out yeah to make
sure it doesn't kick up any dust because
if you breathe it in you get cancer so
these guys come with Max and they're
hosing it down and they're putting it in
bags and they're disposing it this [ __ ]
is in kids lipgloss
yeah that's pretty bad what the f I can
get a good deal on it now though yeah
that's probably true I'll show up that's
optimistic it is being recalled though
so but there you have it and so I guess
the FDA's been going over all these
beauty products and [ __ ] I'm so glad
to hear that because there's some weird
[ __ ] out there on the market I was
touching on an earlier in the episode
these people are making drugs sleeping
pills supplements and they're just
youtubers these are just these are not
chemists these are not they have no
qualification to be making things that
you consume in your freakin body these
have not been you know looked at by the
FDA so now they are looking at it goes
like oh [ __ ] these people are sound like
straight-up poison that's the asbestos
mobile my dudes well it's actually it's
pretty wild that the FDA is inspecting
and regulating cosmetics but yeah I mean
as far as I know they don't they don't
even touch supplements and [ __ ] right
like they don't even well investigate
that it says it always says on the label
not inspected by the FDA I think if they
get certain complaints with tips then
they look into it I look into it they
investigate if there's something
dangerous on the market but this just
goes to show you what like the care that
goes in they find some [ __ ]
manufacturer in China to make it cheap
as possible and these [ __ ] are
putting asbestosis in for god knows what
it's a cutting cocaine with baby powder
it's like why did you use baby powder
well I don't know it's cheap filler and
then they this was fantastic what they
said in their defense they go we stand
by the safety of this item as small
traces of asbestos are acceptable under
European and Canadian cosmetic safety
regulations okay I like our regulation
where it says no [ __ ] asbestos yeah
that seems like a better one there their
argument is well it's OK in Canada it's
fine in Europe bro
[ __ ] no that's actually surprising to
hear I mean and I don't know
also it's probably out of here it's yeah
I'm used to America being like yeah a
little rat poison is fine
right yeah are the ones that are like
usually the other way around but it's
misleading too because they say trace
amounts we're not sure how much asbestos
is in their lip cloths because they're
like well it's okay to have trace
amounts in Europe ours would be illegal
there too but it's okay to have a trace
amount you know what I mean like they
could be well over that trace amount
well I definitely am I'm just thrilled
to find out that the kids are eating
asbestos I mean hopefully we can we can
sneak some lead in there and and call it
a day
lettuce best the house I'm pretty sure
Alex Jones are selling some lettuce
pesto supplements I'm telling you man
do not buy supplements from these
[ __ ] social media people I'm telling
you these people are not qualified to
sell you [ __ ] cosmetics no you know
these beauty gurus are all these Beauty
people getting so [ __ ] rich what is
what these cosmetics [ __ ] it's good
racket I guess I mean Kylie Jenner is a
billionaire right right from selling
[ __ ] lip gloss Jeffery stars like a
trillionaire from selling lipstick and
[ __ ] I mean what the [ __ ] man she's like
also like Rihanna was like were six
hundred million dollars now I just saw I
read something from from cosmetics Jesus
Christ I got to make cosmetics what can
i sell i got to make vaseline ethan
klein Vaseline there you go super super
trooper vaseline what about like a Fupa
rub cooper if i'm sort of rub somehow i
don't see that having the product peel
to make me a billionaire i gotta figure
it out would you guys buy some cosmetics
what would you be interested in got
women man I need female audience sorry
all the
and watching but I can't fleece you
enough I need to work on my female audio
because you could sell females a
fuckload more than you guys you know
they mean yeah like look at Dan's shirt
oh we got new shirts Wow
it's not gonna make me a billion h3h3
shop comm Super Troopers army and
there's another mega billion this is the
bring in danila shirt way [ __ ] two more
yeah that's not gonna make me billion
dollars though sorry guys just not
valuable as females I could sell them
lip gloss with asbestos in it the thing
about all those cosmetics ooh is that I
bet you that cost like 25 cents to make
22 cents of it is the packaging and they
sell it for a hundred [ __ ] dollars
like the the per the markup on that [ __ ]
is insane and why is it that every
beauty guru on YouTube has products has
a lie somehow they're all just chemists
they all just understand how to make
supplements you know makeup is one thing
but when I found out there making
supplements [ __ ] that you actually eat I
was like oh mama
you couldn't [ __ ] pay me to put that
[ __ ] in my body
it's probably just hate yeah and
asbestos asbestos yeah little specialist
little lad a little hey little extra
flavor so then this this story continued
so that was Jojo who was caught selling
asbestosis go god bless her and then
there's another one named J Jaclyn hill
who was selling lipstick with mold
that's right
straight up hairs and mold nasty [ __ ] yo
again sorry lady just because you're
like putting on makeup doesn't mean
you're qualified to make it come H here
this is how it arrived all hairy and
bumpy and [ __ ] this is people tweeting
at her like what the [ __ ]
look this girl found a bead in it she
found a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
she found a bead in her [ __ ] bro that's
a lump of asbestos
she's a lump of lead right there my
dudes uranium core do not buy products
from youtubers cosmetics sorry now this
one she's refuting this or she's
battling it with the Jojo one you know
they pulled all the products and
everything FDA it's like it was no yeah
it's Jojo like is she just hiding her
head from public what's going on yeah it
doesn't see there there was like an
apology statement just a very generic
apology statement in that that's hi guys
Jojo here yeah sorry for showing you a
lip gloss with asbestos alright catch me
my Jojo car like her pipe shootout like
asbestos powder lime locust who dries
well what do you think our plate is
asbestos yeah it's poison Queen it's it
smells poison Queen off and like PSN you
know there's [ __ ] hairs on this one
dudes hairs she says they are fibers
from cotton gloves used at the factory
that's that is so dumb why first of all
at a cosmetic plant if you have workers
using cotton gloves
you already are working at such a
dime-store unprofessional factory that I
wouldn't be surprised if there's mold
and asbestos and lead in your lipstick
why wouldn't you use the latex gloves
who the [ __ ] would use cloth gloves and
if they did why are they rubbing the tip
of the makeup its embedded inside of the
lipstick that literally doesn't make
sense yeah it's kind of hard to there's
no [ __ ] way they were using cloth
gloves no way so then this girl actually
she busted out the Micra it's pretty
legit this girl named rah-rah we're
trying to find the Ross of the wrong
we're trying to find Ross of the raw raw
beauty Christie put the [ __ ] under a
microscope check this video up the truth
about Jacqueline Hill cosmetic lipstick
look at these bubbles here all turned up
what are these hairs you dude you're
supposed to put that on your lip that's
so foul it looks like a little pubes
dude oh my god I am discovered oh oh it
looks like there's blackheads on it
those are just air bubbles oh is what I
believe why are there air bubbles on it
why is there air coming from within it
do you know what produce produces air
bubbles bacteria that's a good point
that thing is awesome I want to get yeah
how'd she get her hands on that that
thing's cool that's so sick anyway so
disgusting so [ __ ] disgusting so she
responded Jacqueline Hill responded she
said if any of you are receiving
lipstick like this please know that this
is not hair I'm afraid it's something
much worse my factory used brand new
white gloves to do quality control and
they shed all over my product we
switched to rubber gloves two days ago
and we'll make sure this never happens
again what about the ball what about the
bubbles nobody's using cloth gloves for
quality control anywhere in the world
for so many reasons one being it's way
more expensive than latex gloves
and two it's way less sanitary than
latex gloves it doesn't make any sense
to use cloth gloves anywhere ever anyway
where does anyone use cloth gloves go
ahead and tell me I'll wait go ahead
when does anyone use cloth gloves for
handling anything jewelry stores okay
jewelry stores maybe you're right I
think they're using blade time yeah no
they use cloth okay fine Zack all right
Zack jewelry anywhere else anyone else
that's all I mean would you say would
you would you say that jewellery is
porous and connect and soak up cloth
mm-hmm well not the good [ __ ] there you
have it there's no [ __ ] way this is
right nasty [ __ ]
also this was a great little thing [ __ ]
Kylie Jenner and [ __ ] all these
Kardashian's so stupid even after they
got in trouble for promoting the fire
festival
here's Kylie Jenner she posted a
promotion for this lipstick and then
quickly erased it once the people were
finding hairs and [ __ ] in it how the
[ __ ] who's paying her she posted it
after the controversy had already kicked
in she probably just added schedules
yeah twice about it right look at this
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ] it looks like the
[ __ ] sorting hat from Harry Potter I
mean she had explanations for for
everything in her in her video you know
but but just when you add up all about
the ball Dan yeah I don't think she
mentioned the ball to be honest looks
like a wanker came oh oh did you think
that was a solid ball no that's just a
cloth from the gloves oh yeah yeah right
so why not how was this even worth her
time like literally she's a billionaire
she probably should probably even touch
her Instagram she was like a manager
we just cused this [ __ ] up and just
keeps the money flowing [ __ ] me man yeah
see any specialist on your lips don't
see any lead could you rashes I don't
see any rashes or rashes from these
things too right because no people were
getting rashes yeah
that ain't right that's just disgusting
that is so foul so in short my dudes do
not buy supplements or cosmetics
anything that requires chemistry please
don't buy from youtubers ever go to
Johnson & Johnson these guys been in the
game for years these [ __ ] wear
rubber gloves you know what I'm saying
these guys know how to make [ __ ] safely
they do not use asbestos why would they
use asbestos I imagine just some Chinese
factory in the middle of nowhere next to
like a toxic polluted river you know
it's like a Green River just using water
from the river to make the cosmetics
[ __ ] nasty there you have it
pretty funny stuff this scared the [ __ ]
out of me little Sam is crazier than I
thought and this video really [ __ ]
little zan we talked recently about him
that he has a zero A zero IQ and this
kind of continues that saga let's watch
it and then comment on it apparently
this guy little zan says something like
two parks are boring and obviously
caused a lot of stirred a lot of
controversy so this guy was just like
hey dude you know [ __ ] you or whatever
for saying that [ __ ] about my boy to my
buyback so this is what ensues
afterwards look a little Zen pulling a
gun right now
thank you
hey look at this guy pulling the gun
right now look at this [ __ ] hey
put that [ __ ] out again homie homie you
will [ __ ] yeah that's why yeah yeah
yeah yeah so imagine being so
unintimidating that you can point a
[ __ ] gun at someone and not faze them
like this guy was so unfazed by having a
gun pointed at him by what seems to be
someone who is constantly under the
influence and unpredictable and still
was like you were such a little [ __ ]
I'm not even scared I mean what I would
have [ __ ] run my I would have been
like see ya I don't want a gun pointed I
mean I get scared when I see little zant
pointing a gun at him cuz it looks like
he's pointing it at me when I look at
the screen that scares me you know what
I'm saying
but [ __ ] this kid man dude this guy is a
menace to society bro you get a little
[ __ ] talk to you and you pull a gun like
get the [ __ ] out I hope he gets arrested
I hope this kick is thrown in jail that
is so insane to pull a gun on someone
like that yeah holy [ __ ] he's trying to
claim that he pulled it in self-defense
cuz he was
okaywell idiot intimidate it well I mean
we don't know what happened before the
video not to defend him deficit that he
doubt that that really had a gun to be
pulled but like you can disprove it
watching this video I mean he only pulls
his gun after they're walking away from
each other sure like you can see here
that guy's walk away
also by the way in California you can't
just cruise around with a gun either you
know what I mean
that's not really a legitimate excuse
he's like treating it like a totally
yeah yeah he's really handling it like a
toy I want you know look a little Sam
pulling a gun right now and dating a
little Zen from the video where he's
probably rolling all over himself
probably cool get out I got a good look
at my car really that's it look at look
at my car
that's all dude ever you and everyone in
LA has a nice car dude you're not the
only one with a nice car I see this car
this is like every other car this
machine in LA look at my car
my gun obviously doesn't intimidate you
this kid is a danger to society this is
truly disturbing you a [ __ ] yeah that's
why yeah yeah yeah yeah look at your car
you little [ __ ] oh what a nightmare
hey he's being investigated for assault
with a deadly weapon what's to
investigate I mean here it is I mean
they they might want to pull video from
before this video starts you know we
don't know I don't I just don't I think
it's safe to assume that yeah well I
mean I mean what if the guy was
threatening him with violence or
something I don't know
I'm not trying to make excuses for a
little Sam but that's probably why they
want to take their time and investigate
get the whole story but yeah I mean I'd
say there's a good chance he's uh I
don't throw anything I mean even if he
was defending himself again he was he
was not by the time he pulled his gun he
didn't seem to be in any any risk any
danger you're right that you can
in the video the dudes walking away when
the gun like here so it's so here he
walks away he just pulled a gun out
right there he his back with yeah that's
pretty cut-and-dry you're right and now
he's walking away after he pulled the
guy yeah this guy pulled a gun pulling a
gun right now this is all over arguing
about to buy that's a good sound but you
need that sound buddy for sure you know
where he's gonna be getting in prison oh
god I really cringed my sauce was like
holy [ __ ] you need [ __ ] out this
guy's really he needs help
this is not the way to live your life ya
[ __ ] hospitalized from hot cheetos
[ __ ] drooling all over yourself while
making a video with your girlfriend
listen I'm Pro I'm pro gun rights
I own a gun I believe but man I hate
seeing this [ __ ] yeah this is not
[ __ ] cool POC made me so
uncomfortable the dock got banned from
twitch this was a good story doctor
disrespect I've been on the show guests
on the show super twitch superstar
recently did his first IRL stream IRL
stream is when you walk around and
livestream just kind of being around
doing your thing and it's the first time
he's ever done that
he usually streams had his computer
playing you know video games and and
I've been watching the Bachelorette and
she always goes and and you guys watch
that show no you know no bachelor nation
tables up hook thought it it's so sad I
can't stop watching that see people
talking about all the time it's really
entertaining like the girl this season
is so undesirable and you have all these
guys fighting for her and you know that
she's so undesirable
she's a total ditz she's not interesting
she's not even that attractive frankly
speaking at least a mite to my taste
I mean she's certainly not like a
supermodel or anything does she [ __ ]
from a previous season yes one of those
and she her ass got cut like she didn't
make it even that deep to be honest with
you yeah but she was like the wild one
yes she she's she was the crazy one you
couldn't help and so she talks like kind
of an airhead and she always goes and
like died I kind of miss those shows I
used to watch the really [ __ ] sleazy
ones on vh1 back in the day like with
Flavor Flav and [ __ ] play the loves
flavor love oh my god dude that [ __ ] was
sold you watch the Bret Michaels one
yeah the Bret Michaels one yeah you
should watch bachelor III it's really
it's so good and it's two hours long -
so you're asking [ __ ] two hours oh yeah
baby every episode two hours that's
great well yeah boy and I'm glued I'm
telling you the production on these
shows cuz there's some that are just
total bad tears garbage like networks
show right it's one of their most
popular shows whatever ABC
yeah ABC I think baby Hannah I'm
incontinent yeah Hannah B see your
bachelor nations that didn't like one
guy say he loved her like the first
episode yeah he's totally psycho it's
awesome all the other guy this guy Luke
he said on the first day that he's
falling in love with her and all the
guys [ __ ] hate this guy and he's such
a psycho how can you know if you love
someone exactly Zack that's gotta be
scripted then yeah it's not scripted
he's just crazy well it's not scripted
why is that proof that it's scripted
it's not proof but the guy you you gotta
watch the show the guy's crazy but
that's like two good TV Zack it's not
that you're not ripped it but it's it's
a weird grade yeah yeah no no they are
linked no to behavior sir
no I'm sorry I don't you guys are
watching the season here's what the
thing is that you got all these guys and
they're super competitive and they
probably don't like in a vacuum it was
just them meeting her they probably
won't even be interested in her but
because it's like this Lord of the Flies
kind of Battle Royale
and they're super competitive
they're the only woman in the whole
world basically for these guys who were
there for like you know two months with
just her then it did a their brains get
all crazy like this is the last woman on
earth almost like and like an animal
instigate they had they go crazy well
the guys on these shows are you know
they're [ __ ] hopped up well the best
you know the best part is that all these
guys they're all like super jacked
handsome dudes but all these guys are
just unemployed yeah they're like so
eligible and her too by the way she does
have a [ __ ] job they're all on this
show for like two months like that the
last bachelor like the virgin dude was
any football player he was an
ex-football player but he's already
retired he's not he's he's unemployed
bro yeah he's straight-up unemployed is
ABC pay him or what do they do yeah I
think they pay the bachelor or
bachelorette but like not they pay not
an insane amount not like life-changing
money and then all the other contestants
do not get paid
the Magnum they are straight-up
unemployed Wow
so this this is not that's the part of
the trip that like trips me out about
this show is that you have all these
guys fighting for her who are they're
all unemployed yeah
and they're supposed to get married at
the end of the show she's unemployed
it's like the show ends they get married
and it's like every week it's like crazy
activities and same date helicopter ride
and then when it's done it's just got to
be like oh [ __ ] we're just two
unemployed idiots and I don't even like
you that much and you know the marriage
never lasts
apparently some do Zack you gotta have
hope yeah you gotta have hope the love
exists so I just looked it up and
apparently so you're right the the
contestants they don't get paid at all
mm-hmm and the main the star the either
the bachelor or the Bachelorette they do
get a salary but their salary is
determined by their pay for their normal
job Oh
what she [ __ ] jury duty I guarantee
you know those guys make that much money
though no exactly yeah yeah this is an
article this is actually just from a
couple weeks ago that was a so much she
relevant to the recent it's
you can tell the budget on the show is
like really really insane cuz what's a
network show a network reality show I
mean they yeah and it's it's really
frankly one of the most popular shows
you can tell yeah for two mugging hours
but this is like season like twenty
something I mean but I recommend it's
it's a fun watch it's just fun it's
bachelor nation all day every day where
was I
doc gets banned oh you're going in the
bathroom you know I really don't feel
like talking about this one what can you
say it was stupid yeah and I mean I
think today maybe there's gonna be
finally a follow-up or a video from him
about it but as of the time of this
recording he has not really replied
other than a tweet saying that that was
coming so we really don't have any
updates on the situation you know people
are saying he might be in legal trouble
because of all this well it certainly
possibly here's one shot okay so he did
this four times while at EA now it's
illegal III thank you it's illegal in
California to film within a bathroom
it's against Twitch's Terms of Service
and I'm sure III and the facility that
hosted it is not loving this either yeah
he's got his badge revoked he got kicked
out so you can see these giant blurred
his they're cruising through the
bathroom these are all people here at
the urinal and look at his [ __ ]
dumbass cameraman well the truth is he
knows he's like man we shouldn't be in
here but so this actually this isn't the
worst one the worst one is here he's
theirs at one point he's right at the
urinal and he I mean it's so close to
seeing another dudes junk and it's a
live stream so you'd there's no
take-backs right yeah you can see their
face you can see the junk I think
there's even a kid here at this point
peeing in the back and he did this four
times he clears just such a dumb idea
dude
just such a bad idea and this this guy
is kind of like the he's got a lot of
bad ideas you know it's like every time
he leaves his house he gets in trouble
don't at that Dan that's a good
observation
it's so great that this was his one
first and last IRL stream I believe he
said in his his one and only tweet since
this happened that he fired his his guy
I think he was kidding don't you think
so yeah it seemed ironic I mean
ultimately the responsibility I mean
yeah okay what is the kind he just falls
on with the camera dock needs to be like
stay outside the bathroom oh also it
happened here four times common sense
four times it happens yeah is he
permanently banned or how does it work
well Pleasant now you still at least
suspended people don't know how long he
was banned for there's not been a
statement about it I don't see twitch
making it permanent no he's too
important to the platform anyway yeah I
mean because if they ban him he'll just
go to youtube and keep doing what he's
doing I don't think they I don't think
he's banned but we don't know for how
long he's been suspended but ultimately
I do think this underlies a problem that
we keep seeing on IRL streams is that
people going out into the world
live-streaming cameras there's no
filtering there's no take-backs
and they're doing really dangerous
stupid [ __ ] and so these guys out there
they need to be held at switch suspended
them it is but these guys need to be
more thoughtful out there because you I
mean dude if you showing like a little
kids dick or some dudes dick in the
bathroom I mean all those people have a
right to privacy in the [ __ ] bathroom
for Christ's sake
you can see when he's in there that
they're all like what is going on
everyone's super weirded out that'd be
[ __ ] piss there's there's there's a
great possibility that he would be in
legal trouble from from any one of these
parties involved and frankly speaking he
doesn't really have much of a defense I
would say and I do think these IRL
streamers need a wake up call because
it's just a breeding ground for like
toxic behavior and yeah you know it's
just a matter of we only hear about it
when [ __ ] like this happens but yeah
my impression of the people that do this
is pretty I mean not Doc personally but
like the whole practice of going out and
doing this IRL streaming doesn't seem to
work out pretty often you know I'm sure
there's like there are decent dudes you
know that are conscientious and nice and
good about it yeah again we hear about
the bad ones like but that there are
toxic ones and they're under all this
pressure to do something interesting and
they're you know just they push it too
far and it's a lie that's the part
that's so you're live in an uncontrolled
environment and you just you gotta be
careful either it's a big difference
between being live in the studio I mean
there's only so much that can happen
here in this studio I'm not showing any
kids dicks being at the urinal for
example that's not a possibility any SH
anyway I will I'm very eager to see how
this develops though because I'm
surprised doctor hasn't really said
anything or apologized or explained I
mean as far as I've seen he's just kind
of made ironic statements about it not
really taking it seriously and I I do
think it is quite a serious infraction
that he's done so yeah I mean if he's in
legal trouble although he he would be
best served in not saying anything I
suppose you're right I guess maybe I
wonder if that is you know if you end
indicative of him being in legal trouble
right but he did let me see the one
tweet he did make he just said mishaps
lead to recaps PS my director Alex was
fired that seems ironic to me
[Music]
but he's just promoting his and to be
fair I did see a bunch of clips from
that day careful
I did see a bunch of clips from that day
and was uh I mean it was pretty
entertaining like he was being pretty
funny in convention everything it was
just he he blew it he blew it yep
now he's of great he's a hilarious do it
I mean you know he was a great podcast
cast a great entertainer but I was a ton
of fun
he's just these guys got to be careful
out there cruising in the bathrooms
live-streaming you know you might as
well put the camera over a stall door he
was you know well I'm trying to keep the
show or the show on the short side cuz I
want to get home to my fam and enjoy the
weekend take care of lo Theodore so I
will I will finish it up here but I hope
you guys enjoyed the show I hope that
you laughed and learned along with us
this is your general your your leader
foolish Maximus here to wish you a very
happy weekend a fantastic week ahead may
all of your dreams and wishes come true
your first Father's Day this Sunday oh
is it Sunday yeah you think that I have
earned the right to celebrate Father's
Day because I've only been at like nine
days dude feel better get you something
dude yeah I'm gonna beep it I'm built
out of that a 48-hour [ __ ] marathon
he put you through come on I'm gonna be
all pissed and passive-aggressive all
day
[Laughter]
what what do you want even get me in
here what do you want to eat no I'm
excited it'll be fun I think I'm just
gonna have the family over my dad my
family and we'll just order some food
take it easy
Oh Ellis mom's gonna cook she does this
huge oh she's out here yeah she's out
here nice yeah exactly yeah it's been
great having her here to help us that's
awesome
so she's gonna cook a big old piece for
everybody
she's has this incredible incredible
chef she's she she'll wake up at like
5:00 a.m. a cook until like 5:00 p.m.
and she's just she's crazy but
fantastically before to that so to all
the other dads out there you were
dad's rule and moms drool no model kit
catches good
all right well and and so that's it
that's all I've got to say so we'll see
you next week
ela will probably be back next week I
will see how he's feeling and and we'll
see you then
meanwhile I don't know about if I'm
gonna be making any HD videos probably
not I don't think I'm ready a couple
more weeks maybe I'll start working on
something but here we are all righty so
that's about it guys we love you we
appreciate you keep on foolish Maximus
in it up and we shall see it next week
thank you all appreciate you Tata
[Music]